which youtuber was my new best friend
my BFF I'm friends of all of them ah
good day I'm Druker suffer and we're
killing it over here on escape tonight I
see my best friend probably was Joey
here being friends in real life I was
like he's my go-to stunning amazing
beautiful I've known Justine for so long
so it's just a very natural thing on set
I got along really really well with Olli
and 10 they both were just super laid
back wearing my jacket it's cold in here
I think my favorite would probably be
Tim cuz he's like this mobster khaki oh
yeah buddy has very nice of you know my
youtuber BFF is always Timothy gonna
give you a deep Swedish massage oh yeah
happy injury in the budget so you're
good to go
and she's like one of my closest
homegirls just in life Timothy was
actually the first youtuber I ever met
from when I first started my channel we
would talk for hours on the phone before
I moved to LA my BFF I think it was Emma
we just became close like talking about
like boy balls
I know let you know like just basic
stuff the funny is well all of them are
such comedians funniest is my girl Ava
Matt is really funny
funniest is me yeah for sure probably me
everyone else you know they try Shane
Dawson
his sense of humor is like something
that I really appreciate I like really
raunchy humor
oh my gosh hands down close how was the
funniest onset having fun with Joey oh I
wish he'll give me some of that money
Moselle is hilarious I can't believe it
glozell glozell is absolutely hilarious
okay you know how funny it was basically
you know I know if we're going like
intentionally funny goes out
unintentionally funny lyrics the
craziest for sure was Lele pons Lele
Lele Lele Lele
definitely Lele for sure definitely
lately
Holly no Leigh Leigh Leigh Leigh's nuts
she is wild
she's insane she's an actual crazy
person and I think that's cuz she's a
Viner you know not a youtuber they gotta
squeeze everything into six seconds you
know so it's like she's just
we would just be sitting in the trailer
and all of a sudden she'd be like
screaming and like running across the
room every trying to go to sleep and I
was just dancing and screaming and
everybody's like hey like stop she just
kept tripping her tight it with károly
giant holes everywhere it's just like a
lot of like personal bubble pop she's at
a hundred percent
all the time this I don't think she's
sleep but it was good for the show I
mean it's fun to be around um if you're
you know in a good mood but it was so
fun like a product different energy to
us it like woke us up and we'd be like
alright I guess we're doing it let's go
you